it's time for me to bestow my infinite
lightning and super glowy ice wisdom as
I'm now a day I can give that advice
that's right my horrible personality is
I'm a dad now I asked you guys if you
needed advice
I'm here to help okay I'll fix it don't
worry since Peters is bad now he's
obligated to give his fatherly advice
that's right it's my obligation and Duty
go to Ben it's 3 40 a.m what are you
doing finish this video and then you
sleep stop gaming the whole night you
fool stop scrolling Tick Tock I told you
a million
Shane
have you ever thought about how
different biernes that's kind of cute
like Bernice magazine upbringing will be
being raised in Japan versus in the
states or the UK that is not an advisor
question okay you're just interrogating
me hey at least he won't spawn in Ohio
okay I think he'll be fine
how did you find happiness I feel like I
watched you for years and I never seen
you as happy as you've been recently
there's no easy answer but I think I
started to do things that for me and
build habits for me that was really
positive regular exercise has really
helped me a lot in terms of managing
stress and just getting General Clarity
and feeling like I'm building on myself
in a sense same thing with reading more
and it's also broadened my scope of
thought and how I approach things
struggles looking at my own life
introspective thinking and that sort of
thing I think is really important at
some point to develop but I also think
at some point you just have to make a
choice
because I've seen people that are widely
successful that are still very unhappy
because at the end of the day your life
is never going to be perfect no matter
what or who you are so I think at some
point you just got to be like you know
what I'm just gonna be happy
I can be almost be about all these
things that uh if only this happened how
then I would feel so much better why not
just be happy today I I think myself
included in the past and a lot of people
had this idea that something in the
future is what's going to bring them
this sort of maybe peace of mind and
happiness but I think there's only so
much you can do today right so try your
best today and that should be enough for
you to be happy I feel like I try and it
sounds a bit weird but I try to live my
life as if tomorrow I would hit the fan
I'd still be feel satisfied maybe
there's more things I want to achieve
obviously there's a lot more I want to
do but at least I've been I live my day
uh the way I wanted to do it
does that make sense the right way at
least I don't know okay how do you deal
with intrusive thoughts if you ever have
any sending lots of love to you beyond
Marty and the Doggers thank you okay
this is gonna sound extremely stupid but
trust me this works your brain
is an [__] giving you all these
intrusive thoughts I'm like why are you
doing this
it's like you're just trying to make me
feel bad I don't like this man so what
you have to do is outsmart your brain by
doing something extremely stupid but
I've tested this and I've tested this on
other people and it works don't question
it I realize that you kind of have to
trick yourself sometimes even if it
doesn't make any sense so what I did is
I pretended that I would physically pull
that thought out of my brain and I put a
lot of effort into it to really trick
myself as much as possible
I probably looked insane but I think the
more insane you look the better okay
because you really have to do it so
strongly and I'll explain why later and
then I trigger and then I pulled it out
and then
unironically it works you know why
because next time that thought comes to
you you can just go no I threw that away
I remember it I look like a fool but I
did it I think that's your best defense
right oh that thing no I already dealt
with that done try it maybe help
what was your journey like finding
someone like Marzia as a young person
today it has become even harder I feel
to find someone to truly connect with in
a romantic aspect and find any
meaningful and deeper connection any
advice is welcome me and Marty Ahmed in
a way that is
at least at the time kind of felt
outside of the standard I imagine more
people meet online now than ever before
so hey it worked for us I looked through
a lot of the comments and the thread and
a lot of them were just about this sort
of question so on the topic of
meaningful or deeper connection that
takes time you know we've been how long
we were together before we got married I
think 10 years eight years oh God I
should know this a long time it takes
time to build a deeper connection and
obviously we loved each other from the
start but that love grew more and more
over time you can't rush love I know it
seems romantic to do but it's truly
beautiful when you let it Blossom like
flower I picked up a weird foreign
accent to sound more mysterious
next question I am a classical musician
working on my second degree goddamn
ambitious how do you personally deal
with the worry of working in a creative
field I made art largely for myself as
my own cope but still worry about
whether I'll be able to capture any
public attention thank you and hope you
Marty and Bjorn are doing well thank you
I think it's worth asking yourself why
you want public attention I think at the
end of the day we all want to be
recognized in some sense but I think
answering that question it makes you
realize sort of why you're doing it a
lot of choices we make at the end of the
day come from someone else where there's
the public wanting to recognized by the
public or maybe make your parents proud
or whatever reason at the end of the day
it's not that important no one cares
that much trust me
I guess what I'm saying is getting
public attention yeah it feels great I
love having my fans and I really
appreciate that we can have this
interaction but I've said this before I
was just as thrilled when I had 200
subscribers I thought that was insane I
was just like what
the number now is just ridiculous I
don't feel any different from then and
now in that sense sure there's more
people but I just don't think the joy
should be from the thing itself not what
other people think about it I'm not sure
if that's what you were getting at but I
just saw captured public attention and
wanted to address that sorry that's not
helpful will there be another book
review in the future I know it takes
time and effort uh so thank you for that
I really enjoyed your reviews and ring
kind of my love for reading amazing hope
your little family is doing fine thank
you maybe I don't know I actually been
listening to audiobooks lately don't
know if that's cheating I don't think so
but uh it's been really helpful when you
have a baby and I'm listening to the
Lord of the Rings I read them when I was
a teenager and I remember skipping
through it when there were songs I
thought the songs were like I'm not
going to read a song this is stupid but
as an audiobook is amazing because uh
they sing the songs and I'm like hell
yeah this song slaps and that's where
all the Lord comes from the books too I
don't know when did that come out I read
it at the same time as the movies came
out
2002 I was 14 13. I love them but it's
been really fun to read or listen to
that not much else I'm afraid what's the
thing you look forward to the most about
being a father and husband growing
together as a family this is not me
giving advice you're just asking me stop
interrogating me stuff it I look forward
to everything now I can't wait to show
Bjorn he's everything will be new for
him it's like when you show your friend
a movie for the first time they've never
seen it and you're so excited you're
like I'm so glad I get to show this to
you I get to do that with everything
it's gonna be great
okay here's one that I saw I think half
of them were like Marzia relationship
stuff the other half was this type of
question what advice would you give to
someone who wants to be active but has
troubles sticking to consistency I want
to become more active but I become
discouraged often this is probably so
common but I want to see your take on it
also Marzell top to your new little baby
so cute thank you I thought you was
gonna say like I'm Mark Zeppelin there
but okay
I don't know I don't know sometimes I
feel like there's something wrong with
me his mindset is a healthy normally
functioned person I look insane compared
to her when I have to do certain things
that uh like working out or the amount
of time I've spent on YouTube the past
couple 10 years you know but I'm not
promoting going overboard or me or being
unhealthy I think my point is more that
if you have a goal to do something like
whatever it may be on 10 minutes a day
I'm gonna work out or I don't know
study a language every day or something
like that whatever goal you had I think
to other people when you have a goal
like that and if you want to be
successful at being consistent with it
you kind of have to almost be a little
bit crazy you know maybe it's oh [__] I
didn't do it today but it's midnight on
any and like everyone's asleep oh well
it's been my goal to do this so I'm
gonna do it anyway just to make sure I'm
consistent and I'm not falling off it's
those kind of defining moments I think
where it is a little crazy to do at
certain things at a certain time it's
kind of like when you watch uh joggers
out in the rain right you're like what
the [__] why why are they doing that
well because they they want to maintain
that consistency and the rain doesn't
stop you just from that I don't know if
that's a good example it's crazy but
they're consistent they have a goal and
they're just doing it maybe you just
need to be a little crazy huh
just take my advice with a grain of salt
by the way okay pewter's bolting nicely
as a father of four don't let the CH
don't let the chat bot say and I thought
you're gonna say but you said Dad Bond
fight it it's hard but worth
um sun came in and now I'm way too
Overexposed I'm actually in the best
shape I've been thank you very much me
and Marseille actually sat down before
we had Baron to discuss sort of things
that are important to us that we don't
want to give up because we knew
obviously having a baby is gonna take
more time and working out was definitely
one of those things I'm like I that is
too too good for me I need to do it no
matter what speaking on the crazy thing
even days where maybe I haven't slept at
all and I'm just exhausted I still work
out and it even though it's been far
from anything I want to do but it makes
me feel so much better and rejuvenated
afterwards that I know it's worth it
have you guys bought the Shaker yet it's
available for 20 off enter code
PewDiePie it goes all the way thank you
guys I messed up in this video the
Shakers are sold out they sold out
within 24 hours beer that's amazing
right now
foreign
glad you guys like them and for those of
you who missed out crying about it a
little babies Bjorn wouldn't even cry
just kidding don't worry I got you
another deal from today Friday until
next Friday G fuel has their fall BOGO
sale this is good beer and keep them
distracted you buy one you get one and
Pewdiepie flavor lingonberry is included
in this fantastic deal so take advantage
stock up on G fuel now it's also a great
way to try out different flavors like
caramel apple try it out see what you
want and fancy to grab this deal use the
link in the description and thank you
for supporting G fuel it's a great way
to support this channel I genuinely
appreciate it it's just the best drink
ever Lincoln Berry get two alright
onward video how do you overcome the
dread or confusion of doing something
new or difficult like moving to Japan
having a kid planning the future
Etc I think a good Mantra is that
nothing really good comes easy I don't
know if that's true but moving to Japan
was very difficult and very challenging
and I like to tell myself at the very
least I don't know if I have some
obsessive need to have a positive like a
silver lining on things or a positive
twist but I just think the fact that it
actually was more difficult for us to
and to move to Japan has made me feel
like I appreciate now being here more
than if we didn't go through all that
struggle one of my favorite books uh the
counter Monte Cristo that's sort of the
the message at the end it's truly
beautiful yeah I recommend the book it's
very good you can only reach true
happiness Beyond anyone else if you've
gone through a lot of suffering not like
I've done that but I'm just saying it's
a good way to look at it it doesn't hurt
all right couple more I had a very good
friend but sadly we distance out I
sometimes think of her and I want to
reach out and revive the French just
write your friend dummy here I'll write
the message for you hi I left a comment
on PewDiePie's latest video he told me I
should reach out just want check in how
you're doing mate XD Emoji there you go
you're welcome and for anyone else that
thought the same as cosmos feel free to
use my template
yeah
how do you keep training without getting
born I started doing more uh different
exercises also doing a little more
calisthenics I'm not sure if it's
calisthenics but just like free body
like pull-ups and uh you gotta Flex
myself I just do a little bit of a
little bit of different different
exercises you know all kinds of things
like switch it up a little bit dummy I
started doing bouldering lately and
that's been a fun way to kind of change
my workout around like that that's my
best tip all right last one have you
ever dealt with extreme self-doubt like
I want to quit all my hobbies and give
up on life because I'm not capable of
type self-doubt if so what helped you
overcome it I don't know if I'm
qualified to give advice on this because
I've always had way too much confidence
but I thought about why that is maybe
it's my parents being supported pushing
me to work hard but I thought about it
all as well I've asked a lot of other
people this as well because I think it's
interesting it's something that most
people remember when you bring it up but
they never even thought about it when
you're a teenager or younger there was
all there's usually one person in your
life maybe a teacher or uh even a
stranger that sort of sees you or or
recognize you and you sort of had that
moment you're like oh what I'm capable
what
I remember for me it was my economics
teacher that everyone hated for some
reason because he was kind of a goofball
but I remember in the group project he
told everyone in my group it was like
Felix is really good at like graphic
design and stuff you should make use of
that for this project and I was just
like
what
me little me
common but it meant so much to me at the
time and because I was really interested
in that I didn't really care for much
else
I think small moments like that really
helps to sort of bring up uh build that
confidence up in case you're listening
to me talking about this and you haven't
gotten that you're doing great don't
worry it'll be fine
just try your best and if you have
extreme stuff that just remember
everyone kind of has that at some point
everyone struggles
at the end of the day you know I meet
successful people all all the time I met
a lot of successful people Everyone is
struggling at something you know don't
worry about it too much if you have some
thought and you haven't been feel like
you've been recognized at least for the
time being you can try and instill some
confidence in someone else you know see
be that person that sees someone else I
don't know sounds preachy little Kumbaya
I'm gonna end it there
I hope you guys enjoyed this video I
hope you found it helpful just take it
with a grain of salt
all right bye
as everyone knows only the best dance
use nordvpn with a VPN you can of course
browse the internet safely and securely
and get past all those pesky region
blocks okay next time you try and watch
the show and you get region blocked and
you're like ah damn it now I didn't
listen I didn't sign up to nordvpn.com
PewDiePie like PewDiePie told me I'm a
Fool well I told you know what I'm a dad
now I'm just gonna shame you Shane
disappoint no better
no VPN also has a ton of amazing free
features hooray built in such as threat
protection for example thread protection
is another layer of security it does a
ton of cool things but it also scans
files for you if you download them a
friend of mine clicked on a file that he
shouldn't and he got all of his accounts
hey we've all been there should I click
on that I don't know I guess I got no
VPN it'll be like ah it's good or now
you dummy and my friend actually asked
me hey is there any software I can use
that will help this from The View
anyway your mouth is frothing you're
ready and I'm about to hit you up with
the deal okay here it comes every
purchase with a two-year plan gets a
huge think big right now I'm talking big
discount Plus
four month free and
I won't shame you this is only if you
use the link nordvpn.com PewDiePie it's
risk-free trying out 30 day money back
guarantee
that's nordvpn.com thank you not even
sponsoring this video thank you thank
you